como cada noche karen regresa a su casa
en bella en el sur de portugal
soy yo ya volví después de pasar ocho
horas cosechando olivas y llevando
cargas pesadas este paquistaní descansa
en su habitación compartida en total 20
migrantes asiáticos viven en esta casa
en condiciones poco salubres pero un
javi en una habitación son 5
en otras y
aquí somos dos
khaled obtuvo esta vivienda a través de
su empleador un prestador de servicios
que lo puso en contacto con los
agricultores portugueses le encontró un
trabajo donde le pagan 600 95 dólares el
salario mínimo portugués también se
encargó de conseguir el transporte para
que khaled pueda ir a trabajar junto con
sus colegas por todos esos servicios del
empleado retire el 30% del salario de
cal en una suma significativa
ganó 695 dólares le envió 300 a mi
familia pagó 100 por mi habitación y 150
de impuestos
al final me queda muy poco dinero
alrededor de 30 mil inmigrantes por lo
general provenientes del sudeste
asiático son empleados por
subcontratistas en portugal al igual que
khaled muchos viven de manera muy
precaria estos prestadores de servicios
son discretos uno de sus representantes
aceptables con nosotros con el rostro
descubierto ya firmamos un contrato con
el agricultor y luego establecemos un
contrato con nuestros trabajadores y
pagamos sus impuestos es completamente
legal este sub contratista reconoce
quedarse con una parte importante del
salario de los trabajadores un tercio de
sus ingresos de harper supongamos que
les pagan siete dólares ahora les damos
cinco dólares y nos quedamos con dos con
esos dos dólares nos damos transporte y
vivienda tuvimos muy harán desde 2010 el
fulgurante crecimiento del sector
agrícola portugués ha sido impulsado por
esta mano de obra barata un papel
crucial en no de mira situada más cerca
de las costas esta zona se especializa
en la producción de frutos rojos para
detectar posibles situaciones
irregulares todas las semanas la
florencia de inmigración realiza
inspecciones en los cultivos
en sí donde viene de nepal
ana pereira supervise al control de 400
inmigrantes que trabajan en los
invernaderos
queremos saber si los trabajadores ya
tienen un permiso de residencia o si
llenaron una declaración de interés para
obtenerlo
residentes farmers hoy todos estos
inmigrantes asiáticos empleados por un
prestador fueron debidamente declarados
y el derecho laboral es respetado pero
ese no siempre es el caso
todavía tenemos algunos problemas
principalmente ligados a los
subcontratistas a veces no tienen buenas
prácticas con ellos en esos casos
debemos hablar con los trabajadores y
ver si están sometidos a cualquier tipo
de vulnerabilidad
según algunas asociaciones varios miles
de inmigrantes son víctimas de prácticas
ilegales en el sector uno de ellos hay
un decidió renunciar a su trabajo y
abrir un taller mecánico
buenos días hoy trabajaremos con este
este indio de kerala cayó en la trampa
de un prestador de servicios
fraudulentos que lo abordó cuando llegó
el aeropuerto de lisboa
primero pague en mil 560 dólares luego
después de eso pague 170 dólares por los
papeles después fui a trabajar en los
cultivos agrícolas es una mafia
esa mafia es un contratista le pagaba a
tan solo 230 dólares al mes y en los
campos el agricultor portugués tampoco
respetaba la ley igual que trabajaba 14
15 12 horas diarias no les importaba se
hacía demasiado calor por si yo había si
teníamos familia nos trataban como
bestias contactadas en repetidas
ocasiones ninguna de las explotaciones
agrícolas portuguesas aceptó reunirse
con nosotros mantienen la oferta bajo
este sistema para las organizaciones de
defensa de derechos humanos esto no es
una sorpresa de dover
contra grandes propietarios contratan a
quienes les dan el precio más bajo y eso
sólo es posible explotando al máximo en
sus inmigrantes
en su casa son los otros los que vienen
porque en estas condiciones de
explotación extremas hay pocos
portugueses que acepten trabajar hacia
deportividad que aceptado anteriormente
a estos trabajadores asiáticos se
encontraban en la región de alentejo en
10 años las exportaciones agrícolas
portuguesas se han duplicado con este
ascenso cada vez hay más trabajando en
todo portugal